[Musik]
ich bin 25
lieber allein hat sich sieben pakete mir
meine mutter dass ich ein unfall wird
ich glaube dass sie mich nicht liebt und
das tut mir weh
ich denke ich bin unfähig zu lieben
ich verstehe und weil er so nicht nur
ein ausgebuffter geschichten erzähler
sondern auch ein wunderbarer arrangeur
von bildern ist weil seine filme an
einigen der schönsten orte von paris
spielt im palais chaillot im palais de
tokyo im musée d'art moderne ist dieser
film nicht nur ein experiment im
geschichtenerzählen wenn auch ein großer
visueller genuss
[Musik]
es geht um eine junge frau die zum
psychotherapeuten geht weil sie ständige
schmerzen hat und behandelt werden will
die sich in den therapeuten verliebt er
sich in sie die beiden bilden ein paar
und plötzlich sieht sie auf der straße
seinen doppelgänger
[Musik]
so ist ein spieler ein virtuose des
kinos der immer schon daran interessiert
war
die normale logik auch die normale
reihenfolge der bilder in seinen
geschichten aufzulösen wer von uns
beiden ist verführerischer das weiß ich
nicht
so spielt mit dem grundsätzlichen
falschen schein des kinos in dem er
verdoppelt indem er in seinen filmen
ganz real lügen erzählt konjunktive
bilder die wir glauben bis wir erfahren
dass sie nicht gestimmt haben
[Musik]
das heißt er zieht uns sozusagen den
boden rücklings unter den füßen weg und
zeigt uns zugleich dass das was wir
gesehen haben auch wenn es eine
erfindung war ja tatsächlich auf der
leinwand wirklich war